Land und Brecht
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus
doch im Kopf weißt doch andere heller
die warenabenteuer sind im Kopf
ist so würde ich sagen JA oder hallo
Schmidt gesagt hat die Welt der Fantasie
ist die wahre Welt der Rest the
nightmare ja ein Albtraum ist ein gut
ist ein gutes Stichwort sichert eine
Albtraum erlebt je nach Sichtweise auch
gerade Markus Söder oder Hubert Albaner
je nachdem wie man gerade ist ja und es
ist interessanter Fall dieser Fall
einfacher weil er so vieles berührt was
ja so mit unserem Leben mit unser aller
Leben zu tun hat ne mit der Frage ist
die Jugend ein besonders geschützter
Raum wo man auch mal unfassbar
bescheuert sein darf ist neulich Harald
Welzheim mit ihm kurz nach der Sendung
noch mal darüber gesprochen er meinte
hoffentlich holt nie irgendeiner das
raus was ich mit 16 so fabriziert habe
weil man ist niemals im Leben so
dermaßen bescheuert und verblödet wie
mit 16 17
das da hat er recht es geht aber im Fall
alwanger finde ich mittlerweile um
eigentlich viel mehr und eigentlich auch
um was anderes als dieses reine
Flugblatt sondern es passierte etwas was
ich interessant finde worüber ich mit
dir gerne reden würde in der impfte
warte damals hat sich ja Hubert Aiwanger
so als Kämpfer gegen das Böse ist Tablet
ja etabliert klassischer Trump Rolle
genau genau
in Berlin ja und der Mann aus dem Volker
mit dem gesunden Menschenverstand auf
der anderen Seite so und damals hatte er
etwas gemacht das ist ja sehr
interessant wenn man das in der
Retrospektive sich noch mal anschaut hat
damals bundesweit sehr viel
Aufmerksamkeit gekriegt war dann auch im
Fernsehen häufiger auch in dem
Gesprächsrunden zu Gast und so weiter
und dann als das Thema sozusagen nicht
mehr so richtig zog hat er sich heimlich
empfohlen lassen ja
wirklich sehr interessant und jetzt in
dieser flugblattaffäre versucht der
erneut sozusagen diese trotz Strategie
wie es Robin Alexander neulich in einem
sehr guten Text genannt hat und
unterschreibt einfacher möchte diese
Angelegenheit irgendwie nicht richtig in
Ordnung bringen er will nicht sagen
warum mal 17-Jähriger komische
Flugblätter mit sich herumgetragen hat
die die das Andenken an die Opfer der
nationalsozialistischen
Vernichtungslager komisch haben
also sozusagen verstörende ja ekelhafte
genau das sagt ja auch selber aber er
will sich gleichzeitig nicht erinnern ob
er die verteilt hat oder ob er sie im
Gegenteil eingesammelt hat er verlangt
ihm zu glauben dass er nicht der
Verfasser ist sondern sein Bruder er
will aber auch nicht über seine damalige
Welt Anschauung so richtig sprechen
Hitlergruß ab dem vorgeworfen wird die
Judenwitze hatte auch nicht gemacht den
Huhn
erinnern Gedenkstätte genau Sprüche wie
negersau sind auch noch nie gefallen er
will also nichts erklären über diese
Jugend in einer kleinen Stadt an der
typischen deutschen Kleinstadt auf deren
Friedhof 67 KZ-Häftlinge begraben liegen
die einen Todesmarsch aus Dachau nicht
überlebt haben erst streitet er alles ab
dann sagte einige Tage nichts ja dann
besteht er darauf als Erwachsener kann
Antisemit gewesen zu sein später sagt er
er war nie Antisemit und erst auf Druck
ringt er sich zu einer Entschuldigung
durch die ich ihm in dem Moment auch
abgenommen habe wählt aber diese
relativierende Formel wenn ich Gefühle
verletzt habe ja und
Gipfel dann aber in einem Satz das ganze
Interview mit den Kollegen von der Welt
in meinen Augen wird die Schuhe hier zu
parteipolitischen Zwecken missbraucht
also er sieht nicht die Opfer er sieht
sich als Opfer und das ist schlimm
[Musik]
jetzt ganz ganz viel auf einmal drin
also das erste ist wenn man wenn man
meint die Stimme des Volkes zu sein und
sozusagen der aufrichtige Kopf ja der
das sagt was die Heuchler in Berlin
nicht so sagen und wir ganze links grün
versiffte mit Spucke und was auch immer
darüber denken mag dann muss man auch
das Rückgrat haben in Situationen wo es
um einen selber geht sich so ehrlich wie
möglich zu machen und diesen Eindruck
hat man nicht also ich kann mich
erinnern dass ich in Schulzeiten auch
mal vor dem Direktor stand wegen einer
völligen Bagatelle ich erinnere mich
aber daran als wenn es gestern gewesen
wäre weil man dann in dem Moment Angst
hat man könnte von der Schule fliegen
was weg wären die Konsequenzen im Fall
von eiwanger stand der vor dem Direktor
oder vor sogar vor sozusagen
theoretisch von der Schule fliegen
können um nicht zu sagen müssen
dass man sich dann an die Details nicht
mehr erinnert dass man sich nicht mal
mehr genau erinnert warum das eigentlich
so war also wenn sein Bruder das
geschrieben hat dann müsste doch noch
diese dieses Unrechtsbewusstsein in ihm
da gewesen sein nach dem Motto jetzt
muss ich mich auch noch aus
kameradschaftlicher Loyalität hinter dem
Blödsinn meines Bruders stecken obwohl
ich ja die Flugblätter nur eingesammelt
habe damit andere die nicht in die
Finger kriegen und so da könnte man ganz
ganz viel darüber erzählen oder es war
doch ein bisschen anders als es
offiziell da gestanden hat und dann fand
den Inhalt des Flugplatz schon ziemlich
gut und so weiter und dann könnte er
sagen wie er damals drauf war warum er
damals so drauf war was das für
Einflüsse waren und so weiter und könnte
auch die Geschichte erzählen wie aus
einem verirrten 16 17-Jährigen also
dieses widerliche Flugblatt damit sich
rumträgt ja ein demokratischer Politiker
geworden ist alles das hat er nicht
gemacht das ist so der erste Teil und es
ist schade ne der zweite Teil ist er
sagt er ist Opfer einer Schmutzkampagne
und ich würde sofort sagen natürlich ist
er Opfer einer Kampagne das Wort Schmutz
würde ich weglassen den Schmutz hat er
fabriziert aber
Schmutzkampagne dass das das klingt so
wie unter der Linie oder seinen
Sexualleben beleuchten oder solche
Sachen das ist ja nicht passiert aber
das ist natürlich viele Journalisten
gibt für die das ein gefundenes Fressen
gibt und die nicht rasten ruhen wollen
bis er aus von der politischen Bühne
verschwunden ist das ist natürlich
richtig ne die springen darauf auf aber
es ist immer zu viel es ist eine
Kampagne aber es ist keine
Schmutzkampagne wenn er den Begriff
Jugendsünde benutzt oder auch Leute die
ihn verteidigen den Begriff jugendzündet
würde ich sofort sagen ja es war großen
Scheiß den man in seiner Jugend gemacht
hat aber das Wort Jugendsünde ist kein
schönes Wort dafür das klingt auch
wieder so albern und vernünftig
also was mir fehlt in der
augenblicklichen Phase ist dieses sich
schonungslos ehrlich machen mit dem was
einem damals für ein Mist durch den Kopf
gegangen ist und was man heute darüber
denkt und das tut er nicht
ja das ist schade ne weil
da ja auch eine Chance drin steckt und
man vermisst dann plötzlich so diese
diese nötige Ernsthaftigkeit ich finde
Markus Söder hat ja echt was
interessantes gesagt er sinngemäß wenn
man das wirklich ernst meint wenn man
sich wirklich aufrichtig entschuldigt
wenn man das spürt das ist ernst gemeint
ist dann gibt es natürlich das Momentum
des Verzeihens ist ja gar keine Frage
aber die die das ungute Gefühl glaube
ich dass manche haben es diese diese
ist es vielleicht beides also Hubert
allwanger war ja vor einiger Zeit bei
uns in der Sendung auch zu Gast und da
hat er das ja ähnlich gemacht was
sozusagen die Taktik angeht ich habe
dieser Tage an Interview gelesen mit
einem langjährigen
Politikberater sondern ganz ausgebuffter
Typ der der Donald Trump schon in
relativ jungen Jahren politisch beraten
hat und der sagte ich habe ihm eine
Sache beigebracht gib nie irgendetwas zu
und wenn sie immer weiter kommen und und
und und mit irgendwelchen Vorwürfen oder
Schmutz so wie erst formuliert hat und
mit Dreck werfen und so weiter gibt's
nie zu entschuldige Dich auf gar keinen
Fall sondern geh einfach frontal du
selber nach vorne also umgedrehen der
täteropfer genau das war interessant
aus meiner Sicht der größte glückliche
Fehler also wir haben schon im Podcast
mal drüber geredet bei der Affäre Wulff
ja warum hat er nicht alles was von ihm
irgendwie diese ganzen blöden kinker
jetzt hier ein Hotelrechnungen und sowas
alles nicht alles auf den Tisch gelegt
und gesagt wenn ihr meint ja jemand der
sowas gemacht hat der darf nicht
Bundespräsident sein dann gehe ich auch
jeder Respekt gehabt wenn der
Beckenbauer erzählt hätte wie günstig
Mann die Weltmeisterschaft gekauft hat
sich dessen am besten noch berühmt hätte
sich zwar strafbar gemacht werden aber
nichts passiert und jeder hätte gesagt
das ist der Franz ne der Franz hat Eier
und so und das gleiche hätte ich jetzt
hier für die richtige Strategie gehalten
sich völlig ehrlich zu machen und zu
sagen ja was für eine ich kann es ja nur
wiederholen in welchem geistigen Morast
man sich bewegt hat als man 16 und 17
war und dann zu erzählen ja richtig
glaubhaft zu erzählen wie man dazu
gelernt hat warum man das heute anders
sieht als damals und und und und genau
das macht er nicht sondern er macht das
trumpmuster er gibt zu was er unbedingt
zugeben muss und den Rest schreitet der
grundsätzlich ab und damit zeigt man
dass man keine Eier hat und gerade wenn
du eine deiner solchen parteivor steht
müsstest du genau das aber eben zeigen
er sagt Sätze wie ich sollte politisch
vernichtet werden er sagt wenn diese
Hexenjagd nicht aufhört dann geht keiner
mehr in die Politik und so weiter ja es
gibt der Teilaspekte das ist ja geil
Aspekte an denen ja durchaus was dran
ist und wo ich ihn verteidigen würde
nicht so sehr als Mensch im Gegensatz zu
Dir habe ich ihn kennengelernt aber
natürlich ist das so man kann nicht an
das Kreuz dessen geschlagen werden was
haben wir mit 16 17 für ein Scheiß
fabriziert hat er hat Wälzer völlig
Recht und da bin ich auch auf welcher
Seite und in diesem Punkt ja in einen
Punkt auch auf Aiwanger Seite was sind
denn das auch für Leute die 35 oder 36
Jahre später meinen sie wissen zu einer
Zeitung gehen und jemand anschwärzen
seiner aktiven Politiker Laufbahn ja
rassistische oder antisemitischen Mister
hat zu Schulden kommen lassen dann kann
man das müssen wir darüber reden
unbedingt und zwar ganz gründlich aber
wenn er mit 16 oder 17 daher in
irgendwelchen verirrten Kreisen
unterwegs war ist das kein Beleg dafür
dass er heute noch ein Nazi ist und das
ist das und jetzt kommt mein wichtigster
Punkt und den habe ich in der ganzen
Diskussion bisher vermisst bei den
enthüllungsversuchen versucht man ja
immer rauszukriegen guck mal der hat
damals schon mit 16 17 und so weiter
dieses Flugblatt da entweder verfasst
oder mit sich rumgetragen oder
verbreitet oder rumgesammelt oder was
auch immer das sieht man mal wieder
wirklich ist ne der hat nur Kreide
gefressen aber ganz ganz tief in seinen
Nazi und diese Küchenpsychologie geht
mir dermaßen auf dem Sack weil es
erstens erstens wir haben Menschen
verändern sich ja also man ist nicht im
Kern das was man mit 16 gewesen ist ja
sondern hat vielleicht eine Menge im
Leben dazugelernt darüber müsste er sich
ehrlicher machen das habe ich auch
gleich gesagt aber dieses überführen
wollen ja jeder Sherlock Holmes ja und
dann gehe ich durch die verschiedenen
heute der Zwiebel durch ja und dann
komme ich auf den wahren kerneiberner
und da ne blitzt mir der Nazi entgegen
und was mich daran ganz besonders stört
ist also nicht nur diese Lust daran ja
jemanden dazu schälen um an irgendein
Kern ranzukommen sondern das ist diesen
Kern bei keinem Menschen gibt den gibt's
auch bei mir nicht und den gibt's auch
bei dir nicht da ist kein Kern in einem
drin kein wahrer Kern indem man
Kommunist Nazi oder was weiß ich was ist
sondern was man wirklich ist verschiebt
sich ständig
ja also wenn man mich fragt was ist das
so sagen deine wichtigste zentrale
Grundüberzeugung muss ich sagen ja gut
es kommt ja auch ein bisschen auf den
Kontext an es gibt Situationen wenn ich
mit dem und dem rede dann ist sozusagen
meine gefühlte politische Position die
schiebt sich ein bisschen nach da oder
sie schiebt sich das gehört zum Mensch
sein dazu man hat nicht diesen einen
wahren Kern den die Journalisten so
enthüllen haben sondern Menschen sind
ein Ensemble von Widersprüchen ja man
ist launisch bis ins tiefste Markt in
sich drin ja man ist ein klein bisschen
auch immer ein wenig Opportunist seiner
selber ganz tief in sich also der dieser
Mensch der immer nur Prinzipien fest
nach einer festen Hierarchie von Werten
in allen Lebenslagen entscheidet den
gibt's vielleicht im Filmen der
existiert in der Realität nicht ein ein
jemand der im Krieg tapfer ist ja kein
gleichzeitig feige sein seiner Frau ein
Seitensprung zu beichten er hat dann ist
man nicht einfach tapfer man ist mal
tapfer und man ist man weniger tapfer
und manchmal großzügig und dann ist man
mal geiziger und man ist grundsätzlich
loyal aber in dem ein oder anderen Fall
hat man auch schon mal jemand verfiffen
so sind Menschen und hier wird mir
völlig falsches Menschenbild erzeugen es
läuft immer auf dasselbe hinaus ganz
tief drin ist der nazii
das
genau der Kern glaube ich um den sich
ganz vieles in der Debatte auch dreht
und das war übrigens ich musste da ein
bisschen widersprechen du sagst es so
ein Aspekt über den noch gar nicht
gesprochen und ich finde ja in in
vielerleibe Hinsicht wurde genau darüber
berichtet man hat hat genau diesen
Vorwurf der Süddeutschen Zeitung gemacht
und hat gesagt wie könnt ihr diese Linie
ziehen wie könnte sagen da gibt es eine
direkte Linie von dem 16 oder
17-Jährigen einwanger damals bis zum
Aiwanger mit gut 50 Jahren der dann in
Erding steht und sagt wir holen uns die
Demokratie zurück ihr habt ja wohl den
Arsch offen und so weiter und dann
sozusagen damit zu überlegen guck mal da
ist ja genau dieser dieser braune Kern
den du gerade gesprochen hast und es
interessant in eine ganz ähnliche
Richtung und wurde dafür tierisch
verprügelt ging Sigmar Gabriel dieser
Tage der glaube ich irgendwo im fernen
Ausland gerade weilt das aber dennoch
alles verfolgt und folgenden Satz
schrieb warum sollen junge Neonazis aus
der rechtsextremistischen Szene
aussteigen wenn sie am Beispiel Hubert
Aiwanger gerade erleben dass man auch 35
Jahre später noch für den Wahnsinn der
eigenen Jugend derart öffentlich
gebrannt wird
gutes Argument was willst du sagen sehr
gutes Argument ja also ich würde das ich
würde das sofort sagen also wenn wir in
unserer Gesellschaft den Menschen das
Recht auf lernen und auf Veränderung
absprechen dass der Punkt dann verfolgen
wir nicht nur völlig falsches
Menschenbild sondern dann kommen wir in
eine ganz üble Welt ich meine wie soll
sich denn also ich meine natürlich ist
das schön wenn wir kein Jugendlichen
hätten die braune Schriften in den
Schulen verteilen
aber wenn jeder schon als 1670er Jahren
die ich Schere im Kopf haben muss was
auch immer ich hier jetzt gerade tue ja
wird mir in einer zunehmend
moralisierenden Gesellschaft ein Leben
lang alles verhageln ich meine welchen
Geist oder in welcher Freiheitsgeist
sollen dann eigentlich junge Menschen
herangeführt werden das ist keinerlei
Verteidigung für rechtsradikales
Schrifttum in der Schule das ist aus
guten Gründen geächtet und verboten aber
es ist natürlich eine Warnung vor einer
übermoralisierung der Gesellschaft die
nichts verzeiht genau das ist
interessant weil du gerade sagst Schule
ne ist auch interessant für die Schule
damals umgegangen ist mit mit der
causaiwanger es gibt ja auch ein zweites
Argument dass ich ich finde ein
gewichtiges Argument das Argument zu
sagen Schule ist ja in gewisser Weise
ein geschützter Raum ja das ist ein Ort
der Entwicklung der sich Ausprobierens
der sich austestens und des austestens
auch die Grenzen und so weiter und
deswegen ist es ein besonders
geschützter Raum wir reden über
Minderjährige wir reden über Kinder wir
reden über Jugendliche und die müssen
wissen dass es sozusagen diesen Raum
gibt der der beschützt ist und der der
quasi wie eine Brandmauer nach draußen
ist deswegen schaltest du dann auch
nicht die Polizei ein deswegen fängst du
nicht an das ganze Ding an die ganz
große Glocke zu hängen nach meinem
Gefühl haben diese Lehrer damals die
Schulleitung damals die haben das
eigentlich gut gemacht nach allem was
man so von außen sehen kann die haben
sich waren sich genau dieser
Verantwortung bewusst und wenn du jetzt
hergehst und zerst das sozusagen ans
grelle lichteröffentlichkeit dann tust
Du etwas was du eigentlich nicht geht
und ich habe dieser Tage an Gedanken
gelesen den ich interessant fand auch
als 80-jähriger ja wirst du nach
Jugendstrafrecht verurteilt wenn du
irgendetwas mit 14 15 16 oder 17
verbockt hast
weil du damals an anderer warst das ist
der Gedanke sozusagen dahinter ja du
ziehst nicht den 80-jährigen zur
Rechenschaft sondern siehst den den
16-Jährigen im heute 80-jährigen zu
Rechenschaft das ist ein guter Gedanke
finde ich absolut absolut also das ist
das was ich gerade sagte wir müssen das
Veränderungspotential unterlegen den
Reifeprozess von Menschen und so weiter
berücksichtigen oder Strafrecht macht
das ja in dem Jugendstrafrecht halt
anders ist als das Erwachsenen
Strafrecht und das gute Gründe das so zu
tun und das ist auch einfach richtig
also wenn du jetzt sonst sagst jemand
kann ein Leben lang als Erwachsener wie
ein Erwachsener für das beurteilt werden
was er mit 16 gemacht hat geht das auch
für das was er mit 10 gemacht hat
die Grenze ein also wenn wir bestreiten
das ist eine Entwicklungsfähigkeit des
Menschen gibt weil man ja ein
teuflischen oder göttlichen Kern in sich
trägt der unverrückt war ist ja der den
waren Charakter in einem beschreibt wenn
wir tatsächlich so ein Bild hätten dann
könnten wir bei drei oder vierjährigen
anfangen die vollständige Verantwortung
zu übernehmen nein also wir haben gute
Gründe das nicht zu tun und diese Grenze
ich meine heute ist ja die die Zeit der
Reife man in einigen Bereichen viel
länger noch als früher also in einigen
Punkten sind 18 Jahre 18-Jährige heute
viel viel erwachsener als wir damals und
erst recht meine Eltern und Großeltern
und den anderen Punkten haben sie eine
viel viel längere Kindheit und Reifezeit
und diese Kindheit und Reifezeit die
räumen wir als Gesellschaft Menschen
auch heute gerne ein also sozusagen die
Spielphase im Leben ist heute viel
länger als früher nur mit 14 kamen 90
Prozent der Bevölkerung früher in die
Lehre und musste sich wie Erwachsene
Verhalten ja und heute kann man noch mit
25 irgendwo so nicht wissen was man ist
oder auf der Suche nach seiner wahren
Sexualität sein oder auf der Suche nach
seinem Sinnen und nach seiner Rolle und
seinem Glück und so das wird ja auch
Menschen heute zugestanden ist auch gut
so und früher wurde er bei ab 14 musste
man ja funktionieren wie ein Erwachsener
und wenn wir auf der einen Seite eben
zugestehen dass Menschen eben lebenslang
Suchende sind und sich auch verändernde
dann können wir nicht in den wenn wir es
mit einem Politiker zu tun haben der
großen Teilen der Presse aus Gründen die
sie weiß und die sie kennt und warum das
so ist um die sam ist dem das absprechen
dass er in der Lage ist ein
Entwicklungsprozess durch zu machen und
ich sehe einen großen Unterschied
zwischen diesem
ekelhaften
Flugplatz das damals gemacht wurde und
der Entgleisung von Hubert Aiwanger als
er sagte wir holen uns die Demokratie
zurück so das ist nicht das Gleiche ja
das erste ist richtiger nazi-scheiß
gewesen ja übelste nazi-witze und das
zweite ist trumpismus und das ist nicht
das Gleiche ja jeder Populist redet so
ja wir holen uns unser Land zurück wir
sind die Ware Demokratie und so das ist
der sprech von Populisten in aller Welt
das ist aber kein Ausweis control ne ja
es ist genau das gibt's beim brexit das
wird bei Trump ich nehme an dass die
Rasse wahrscheinlich relativ wenig
und so
das ist aber etwas anderes als ein
überzeugter Nazi zu sein der Witze über
den Holocaust macht das sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge und wir können nicht
die Nazi Grenze 1 cm rechts von der
Mitte anfangen lassen ja und häufig habe
ich in der Öffentlichkeit dieses Gefühl
also für Jan Böhmermann ist ja jeder der
rechts von der SPD steht irgendwie ganz
schnell unter Nazi Verdacht und wenn wir
so Kollektiv alle Leute die irgendein
rechtes Gedankengut haben direkt als
Nazis brandmarken dann nehmen wir
natürlich dem dem Nazi Begriff ja die
Schärfe ja wir schaffen einen riesiges
monstrumiboliöses Monstrum wäre dann
alles an Nazis und so weiter und das
wird dann dazu dass wir wahre Nazis
nicht mehr von ganz normalen rechten
unterscheiden kann
meine dieser inflationäre Gebrauch des
Begriffs Nazi das schlimm ja also ich
das letzte mal richtig übel aufgestoßen
ist es mir muss ich wirklich mal der
Deutlichkeit sagen als plötzlich die CDU
Friedrich Merz es waren dann plötzlich
auch Nazis mit Substanz Zitat jan
Böhmermann furchtbar dachte wie wie kann
man sowas sagen
auch nicht du frag ihn mal wenn du ihn
beim nächsten Mal triffst du hast ja
schon mal mit ihm diskutiert also ich
finde dass uns wirklich diskutieren nein
aber ja ja ich finde das völlig
unsäglich also abgesehen mal von der
moralischen Selbstgerechtigkeit dass sie
ein Böhmermann entscheidet wer in
Deutschland Nazis ist und wer nicht ja
und hier mit holzhackerischer Sicherheit
sich zutraut Urteile zu fällen also
finde ich schon wirklich schlimm also es
gibt Stufen des angemessen Moralismus
die einfach nicht gesund sind für die
öffentliche Debattenkultur
warum sind wir in genau dieser Situation
warum wird sie sind wir so eine komische
Gesellschaft also erstmal würde ich mal
sagen es gibt eine interessante
Parallele zwischen dem was heute
passiert wo also jeder sich klar
bekennende konservative in der CDU in
manchen Kreisen bereits als Nazi
tituliert wird früher war das umgekehrt
in meiner Jugend wurden linke
Sozialdemokraten als Kommunisten
beschimpft da war übrigens Kommunismus
und Schlimmeres Schimpfwort als Nazi
weil die Angst die Gefahr kam ja kam ja
aus der Sowjetunion ne oder außer DDR
oder wie auch immer das große Feindbild
war ja nicht so sehr der Nazi da hat man
sich ja mit dem aufarbeiten manchmal
auch wirklich lange Zeit gelassen
sondern das hauptfeindbild Wohl von dem
man die Gesellschaft bedroht oder war
von Kommunisten oder Krypto Komponisten
untergrundkommission und wie man die
alle genannt will Zeitungen ist das sehr
breit mit umgegangen
ist und Herbert hinein natürlichen
Kommunist und wie die branden Kommunist
und so weiter das heißt da hat man also
Kollektiv den Begriff Kommunismus für
alles umliebsame eingesetzt was auch nur
ein ganz klein bisschen sich getraut
hatte Links zu sein und heute erleben
wir
glückliches Gespenstes Kommunismus ist
weg Kommunist ist eigentlich kein
Schimpfwort in der Gesellschaft mehr
weil es so gut wie keine mehr gibt und
das gleiche erleben wir jetzt dass der
moralische Kompass also immer auf der
Suche ist oder der Geigerzähler ne immer
guckt irgendwo was es irgendwo einen
verkackt dann hat sie
ja offensichtlich braucht die
Öffentlichkeit sowas ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob die Öffentlichkeit das braucht
aber einige Massenmedien aber einige
machen Medien haben großen ja ich meine
mit der Öffentlichkeit sagen wir mal die
veröffentlichkeit ja also die mediale
Repräsentation der Öffentlichkeit die
und da hast du recht mit der
Öffentlichkeit natürlich nicht identisch
ist
was ich damals weil du gerade Jan
anspricht jan Böhmermann ich der sich
auch gerne mal mit uns beschäftigt
beschäftigen uns jetzt mal mit ihm finde
ich gut weil gerade jetzt der Anlass mal
da ist damals in dieser Diskussion auch
auf diesen auf dieser Zeit Veranstaltung
ja Giovanni di Lorenzo wir sitzen da im
Hamburger Michel und diskutieren gegen
um Corona und so weiter und da hatten ja
damals vorgeworfen die berühmt
berüchtigte falls Balance ja das haben
wir auch Kolleginnen vom Spiegel
vorgeworfen irgendwie da wurde ich ja
gefragt wie es denn sei für den Tod von
tausenden von Menschen verantwortlich zu
sein willkommen im Club ist mir auch
schon vorgeworfen worden ja und zwar und
zwar deswegen weil wir das Vergehen
begangen hatten ähm Hendrik ab und zu in
die Sendung einzuladen das war der Grund
für den Vorwurf für den Tod von ihm ich
zitiere Tausenden von Menschen
Zitat ist auch genauso gefallen das
wurde hinterher doch noch bestritten hat
jemand dann aber auch öffentlich noch
mal wieder überholt und deswegen mache
ich es jetzt auch öffentlich und das war
damals die die Geschichte auf diesem auf
diesem auf dieser Zeit Veranstaltung und
der warf mir auch diese diese falls
Balance vor und raunte da so und also
nach dem Motto ich bin ja dann auch
dafür verantwortlich dass da Menschen
sterben das fand ich damals alles sehr
ungut und ich sag dir warum ist ungut
fand dann war auch plötzlich jemand wie
Alexander Kekule jemand den man nicht
mehr einladen durfte
mögliche Position vertragen so
ein bisschen ambivalenter betrachtet hat
die steigt das gemacht hat und die
Kollegen
gehauen genau Relativierung von Corona
ja genau gut gut dass du es noch mal so
sauber erklärst und der weißt du was
mich damals wirklich gestört hat ich
habe Lust am Streit und ich diskutiere
gerne und das mache ich auch wann immer
es geht und wenn der Streit so zu zu
streiten ist dann dann mache ich das ja
und dann tragen wir das aus und
hinterher sind wir wieder gut
miteinander und ich werde auch oft
gefragt wie eigentlich mein persönliches
Verhältnis Sahra Wagenknecht ist und
gesagt das ist großartig ich schätze sie
ich mag sie man ist freundlich
miteinander und ich tausche mich
wahnsinnig gerne mit Sarah Wagenknecht
aus wenngleich ich viele ihrer
Positionen gerade was was Russland und
so weiter angeht oder den vermeintlichen
Wirtschaftskrieg den wir oder der böse
Westen quasi gegen die Armen Russen vom
Zaun gebrochen hat ich teile dieses
Argument gar nicht weil es einfach eine
Täter Opfer Umkehr ist aber das ist ein
anderer Punkt was mich bei Jan
Böhmermann damals wirklich
zuerst gestört hat und wo ich gemerkt
habe da gibt's so Mechanismus wenn
Comedians oder Satiriker wie er sich
nennt die dann plötzlich argumentativ in
der Ecke sind in der Enge sind das war
damals so das spitzte sich so zu und so
weiter und man merkt ihr plötzlich okay
das das gibt argumentativ möglicherweise
eher in meine Richtung dann nimmt er
immer den Notausgang sortiere sagt du
ich kenne mich ja auch gar nicht aus ich
bin ja gar kein seriöser Journalist und
so weiter ich bin ja nur ein kleiner
satirik und so weiter und man darf ja
wohl mal und das ist etwas was mich
wahnsinnig stört du zündest mit mit
Argumenten haust einfach mal einen raus
und wenn du merkst es geht daneben oder
fällt dir auf die Füße dann nimmst du
den Notausgang
kann ich nicht gut umgehen weil ich weil
ich immer denke nicht man muss schon
klar sein in seiner Sache also macht
gerne Witze dann lachen wir alle
gemeinsam darüber und Verarsche auch
mich äh alles gar kein Thema kannst du
machen jeder der seine Nase in
irgendeiner Form daraus in in diesen
öffentlichen Wind hält muss damit leben
dass der Wind irgendwann von vorne kommt
nicht das Thema das Thema ist aber
dieses das ist eine Form von von von
Feigheit der letzten Endes auch ja dann
steh doch bitte zu deinem Argument kenne
dann Argument vertrete es so dass es
auch wirklich glaubwürdig und konsistent
ist und dann bleibt auch dabei aber sag
nicht da gibt's jetzt irgendwie diesen
Notausgang und den nehme ich immer dann
wenn es eng wird es geht nicht also ich
glaube dass das Problem ja viel größer
ist als die Person Böhmermann sondern es
ist wirklich mal interessant darüber
nachzudenken welche gesellschaftliche
Rolle Comedians heute in der
Gesellschaft einnehmen
in den 60er 70er 80er bis in die 90er
Jahren ist es noch keine Comedians gab
sondern nur Kabarettisten waren das im
Regelfall halb oder sehr mutige Leute
deren Aufgabe darin bestand sich mit den
mächtigen anzulegen also so diese Rollen
die Dieter Hildebrandt oder Matthias
Richling und so weiter gespielt haben
und einige noch sehr viel mehr an dieser
Tradition steht dann noch volker Pispers
und so der jetzt ja leider nicht mehr
auftritt so und das ist immer immer
sozusagen den Herrschaft des Kurs in
Frage zu stellen ja also das was sie
mehr als Meinung ist oder was die
Parteien vertreten und sowas sozusagen
kritisch und satirisch zu beleuchten das
heißt also man legt sich mit den
mächtigen an dass die klassische Rolle
des politischen Kabaretts gewesen heute
haben wir politische Comedians was ja
jan Böhmermann ist ja erzählt ja nicht
einfach keinen Grund warum politischer
Comedian und was machen die
die brandmarken alles was nicht in
Mainstream liegt also genau umgekehrt
sie sind jetzt nicht sozusagen das
Korrektiv ja dass also das was sowieso
alle denken ja mal in Frage stellt und
überlegt ist das so sondern sie sind
dass sie es bestätigen und die alle die
es wagen den Mainstream in Frage zu
stellen Carolin Kebekus gehört da
wunderbar auch dazu das sind die die
also was sollen die gerade herrschenden
mehrheitsdiskurs da wo ich nenne das ja
immer der Cursor des gefühlten Anstandes
ist ja der wird von den Comedians nicht
in Frage gestellt werden immer
verteidigt
das heißt also sie haben so eine so eine
herrschaftsstabilisierende Funktion
inzwischen übernommen ja Abweichler
durch den Abweichler durch den Kakao zu
dir sind Leute die sich getraut haben
mal eine andere Meinung vorzubringen
oder auch von der augenblicklichen
Mehrheitsmeinung irgendwo abzuweichen
die werden lächerlich gemacht mit zum
Teil drastischer Art und Weise und das
finde ich ist ein soziologisch hoch
interessanter Befund das stimmt hatte es
eigentlich dazu kommen können und ich
glaube da haben wir amerikanische Muster
kopiert ne die die die die Comedian
Landschaft in den USA funktioniert ja
recht ähnlich ja sonst Stewart bis
neulich gehört wenn man eine echte
Legende der der klingt mittlerweile auch
teilweise wie ein Aktivist ich stößt das
irgendwie auf der so geschätzte John
Stewart und denke warum warum muss man
das so machen diesbezüglich übrigens
interessant das ist auch das Problem mit
dem sich Dieter nur gerade rumschlägt ne
ja genau und ob ich jetzt in dem ein
oder anderen
Tradition erstellt also die die nichts
narrative ja in Frage so allgemein im
anderen Punkt und jetzt geht es
überhaupt nicht um die Frage ob ich in
dem Punkt mit ihm übereinstimme oder
indem oder indem sondern es geht darum
dass das eigentlich auch durchaus die
Aufgabe von politischen Comedians ist es
ist der Job aber die Tatsache dass er
das so macht und dass er da witzelt und
Sachen in Frage stellt und so weiter
wird also von den anderen Comedians ja
die so eine Art Scharia Polizei für den
Cursor das Gefühl ja angegriffen und
zwar massiv ich habe ich mit den Satz
wirklich mit den 60 kenn die da nur
wirklich nur so ein bisschen aber Dieter
nur begleitet mich quasi durch meinen
halbes Leben hat hatte früher beim WDR
immer so eine Kolumne bei WDR 2 und den
habe ich ganz oft gehört auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit wenn ich hier wenn ich so über
die A4 ähm bin mit meiner Karriere ja
aber ich ganz häufig Dieter nur gehört
dass wenn man schön und ich habe mit
Entsetzen festgestellt dass der
ehemalige Lehrer der eher mein Augen war
mein Gefühl hat linksliberale litano ist
plötzlich auch so gefühlt so so so ein
halber rechter der kenne nein wenn ihr
weißt du wie das Entstehen gehört Dieter
nur in diese Ecke
sondern der hat ja auch von sich selber
gesagt ne der Gürtel war grünen Wähler
der ersten Stunde wie ich übrigens auch
ja so und dann kann man plötzlich von
Entwicklungen der letzten zehn Jahre
entsetzt sein weil man sagt das ist doch
nicht mehr das Grün wofür ich stehe und
das ist auch nicht wer das Links für das
ich bisher immer gestanden habe sie ist
also eigentlich es ist nicht Kritik von
rechts sondern ist Kritik aus den
eigenen Reihen man kann sogar sagen
Kritik aus der eigenen Vergangenheit ja
das heißt also man wird quasi mit dem
konfrontiert was man doch eigentlich mal
war und darauf reagiert man hochsensibel
und schiebt jeden linken der es wagt
Linke zu kritisieren in die Rechtecke
das ist das was Kollektiv passiert und
das der Mechanismus ja genau ich ich
habe dieser Tage beschäftigt die
deutsche Politik noch immer die causer
ist geschafften Leiters des Bundesamts
für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik eine Schönbohm hast
du den Fall ein bisschen verfolgt
der ist auch eher von Jan Böhmermann
vorgeführt worden
kann man glaube ich so sagen war also es
behauptet worden das Schönborn sozusagen
über ein lobby-verein
einer mit dem russischen Geheimdienst
verwandelten Firma nahe steht ja ist
dann irgendwie veräppelt worden ist
indem wir mit mit einer Clownsnase da
gezeigt worden und so weiter und
diese Recherche die also Recherche unter
Anführungszeichen dass das Thema war in
der deutschen Politik hat dieser Tage
mit jemandem gesprochen der wirklich
tief drin ist sagt das war lange bekannt
und es war auch lange bekannt dass da
nichts dran ist und der
Verfassungsschutz der ja wir haben ja
immer das Gefühl der Verfassungsschutz
ist sozusagen das sind so die die diese
diese Spione die so ihr Ding machen ja
die die die agieren so in diesem ganzen
Graubereich und er im Dunkeln und so
weiter und haben eigentlich mit der
Politik nichts zu tun die sind quasi
unabhängig das stimmt aber nicht sondern
die Innenministerin in dem Fall ist
weisungsbefugt die sagt pass auf guck da
mal hin und das wird jetzt gerade Nancy
fazer zum Verhängnis die dann offenbar
das gesehen hat und der Meinung war okay
dieser Mann ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr
zu halten jetzt muss man wissen der
steht glaube ich tendenziell eher der
CDU nahe und hat das zum Anlass genommen
den Mann rauszuschmeißen stellt sich
jetzt raus der nix mit irgendeiner
russischen Firma zu tun die dem
russischen Geheimdienst nahe steht und
so weiter und ist ein großes Politikum
und wird wird gerade zu einem echten
Thema auch unser Sender hat damit jetzt
ein echtes Thema weil dieser schönen
Bund der ist gefeuert worden macht jetzt
was anderes ist ähm jetzt wartet der
leitet glaube ich seit Januar die die
Bundesakademie für öffentliche
Verwaltung das aber ein exzellenter
Beamter dass das was ich von den Mann
immer höre ein absolut integerer
exzellenter beam von denen Deutschland
übrigens erstaunlich viele hat das ist
etwas dort muss sich auch noch kaputt
machen es gibt in diesem Land wirklich
ein paar exzellent gute Leute
beschimpfen immer so gerne über Beamte
und Verwaltung und ich weiß noch in
unserer Jugend war Beamter zu sein das
war ja quasi so eine Art Schimpfwort
aber es gibt in dieser in dieser
deutschen Verwaltung gerade in der
Spitze so direkt sozusagen hinter der
ersten politischen Ebene ja ähm die die
die die Staatssekretäre und so weiter
und dann auch noch darunter da gibt es
Leute die machen einfach einen exzellent
guten Job die kennen in deutsches Recht
die kennen europäisches Recht die
überlegen hin und her bei
Gesetzesänderungen wegen alle Untiefen
ab sozusagen alle Gegenargumente alle
Argumente dafür sprechen und treffen
dann eine Entscheidung und das ist eine
gute Sache dass wir diese Leute haben
die sind unkorrumpierbar die sind Teil
dieses guten
Deutschlands dass wir haben
glücklicherweise und deswegen fand ich
es auch immer in der Causa Wulff ja der
der arme Wulf hat mir mal leid getan
weil ich dachte oh mein Gott jetzt muss
diese arme Mensch sich irgendwie für ein
Bobby Car rechtfertigen aber das
prinzipiell die deutsche Justiz sagt es
ist uns 20 Millionen wert mal genau
hinzugucken was da wirklich war also es
war auch als Botschaft für alle anderen
so nach dem Motto versucht es erst gar
nicht ja aber es ändert ja nichts daran
wer einmal medial verbrannt ist ja der
der dem haftet die schwarze und der
Brandgeruch ein Leben lang an
ja und das Problem was wir hier haben
ist eben mediale Vorverurteilung ja
schön wo müssen das ist ein ehrlich
gesagt bringt jetzt auch die
Innenministerin in Bedrängnis weil sie
sich natürlich fragen lassen muss wie
kann das eigentlich sein und das ist
geht wohl so weit dass es in diesem
Verfassungsschutzbericht ja wenn der
Innenminister oder Innenministerin
anordnet guckt da mal hin dann gucken
die hin dann kommt das zurück und die
sagen da ist nichts wir haben das alles
abgeklopft und dann sagt man er dann
guck aber bitte noch mal hin so ist es
wohl in dem Fall gelaufen und am Ende
war weg und das ist schwierig und wenn
das dann so medial so getrieben wird wie
es in dem Fall offensichtlich passiert
ist und am Ende wird dieser Mann
entlassen der hat jetzt einen anderen
top Job darum geht's gar nicht aber ich
verstehe dass der Sauer ist darüber dass
der verbittert ist darüber weil ein ein
offenkundig
makelloser sehr integrierer Beamter in
dem Fall zu Unrecht plötzlich sich an
diesem öffentlichen
wieder findet und das Interessante ist
ja auch ich meine du bist Beamter du
bist nicht in der ersten Reihe aber du
findest dich plötzlich in der ganz
großen Öffentlichkeit wieder du bist ja
Beamter weil du genau das nicht wolltest
du wolltest doch jemand in der zweiten
Reihe sein du willst einfach sozusagen
ganz normal ja dann guten Job machen
aber eben nicht sozusagen in der ersten
Reihe medial da wo dieses ganze mediale
Gemetzel stattfindet die ganze Zeit
sondern du willst im Hintergrund in Ruhe
deine Arbeit machen und plötzlich wirst
du da so hingehängt schwierig ja ich
würde ich würde gerne von dort aus zur
eiwanger wieder zurückkehren weil die
Dimension über die wir ja bisher nicht
geredet haben ist die Dimension des
praktischen Umgangs also wir waren ja
Übereinstimmung der Meinung dass die Art
wie er Aufklärungsarbeit über seine
Jugend verrichtet hat dass die
hochgradig defizitär ist und dass ich
dann werde er dann sehr schwaches Bild
abgibt
wir waren uns gleichzeitig aber einig
dafür dass Dinge die man mit 16 17
gemacht haben eigentlich ein Leben lang
zur Last gelegt werden können und wir
sind uns auch noch jetzt wenn ich das
kurz ergänzen darf vielleicht in einem
dritten Punkt einig ich erlebe ja die
Leute im Hintergrund ich habe Hubert
Aiwanger erlebt Roman Deininger von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung saß neulich da der
kennt den wirklich sehr sehr gut weil er
viele dieser Auftritte verfolgt sagt man
hatte öffentlich bei uns in der Sendung
gesagt man mag den ja weil der irgendwie
so noch aufbollt ist der hat Lust am
Streit und so weiter aber das ist kein
böser Mensch ich würde ich kenne nur
sehr oberflächlich aber diese
Einschätzung teilen es war interessant
nach der Sendung ihn zu erleben das war
für den völlig in Ordnung dass ich ihn
hart dran genommen habe das wäre richtig
hart gestritten haben und so weiter es
war von der alles in Ordnung und was
nicht kam und das habe ich mir genau
angehört es kam nicht im Hintergrund
auch dieses komische Geraune gegen
Migranten oder so so halt braunes und so
weiter nichts von alledem wirklich
nichts deswegen würde ich immer sagen
wenn Hubert Aiwanger sagt ich bin kein
Antisemit und ich bin auch kein
Menschenfeind dem heutigen Hubert
Aiwanger nehme ich das zu 100 Prozent ab
ein weiterer Punkt der dazu kommt ist
Schamhaftigkeit und Schamlosigkeit und
wir haben darüber gesprochen wir erleben
eine Gesellschaft in dem der geforderte
Anstand immer höher wird in dem also
nichts mehr durchgeht wie wir hier sehen
auch keinen Scheiß den man mit 16 oder
17 gemacht hat ja wir müssen also
gezwungen jeder Mensch der in der
Öffentlichkeit ist muss ein perfekter
Mensch sein der darf nicht haben dass er
irgendwann mal irgendwo in seinem Leben
irgendwie nicht in Ordnung war weil
anders als in früheren Zeiten findet
sich mit Sicherheit irgendjemand der das
ans Tageslicht hat und eine verpetzt und
jetzt was passiert folgendes wir leben
also in einer Gesellschaft in der also
immer mehr Anstand verlangt wird aber
gleichzeitig immer mehr Anstand verloren
geht
nämlich den Anstand dass man jemanden
nicht für was Wasser vor 35 Jahren
gemacht hat vor pfeift das heißt das Maß
an Schamlosigkeit in unserer
Gesellschaft das verringert sich nicht
es verlagert sich es verlagert sich von
der Schamlosigkeit des Tuns in die
Schamlosigkeit des demontierens und das
ist für die Vertrauenskultur in unserem
Land keine besonders gute Nachricht
offensichtlich gibt es da überhaupt
nichts mehr ach ja der hat noch mal das
gemacht jetzt gehe ich mal
hin und erzähl mal was der da vor 20
Jahren gemacht oder ich erinnere mich
daran der hat doch damals da auf dem
Volksfest da und so weiter ja und das
erzähle ich jetzt mal dem Spiegel oder
der Süddeutschen Zeitung was sind das
für Menschen die sowas tun ja im Namen
des Anstands jeden Anstand fahren zu
lassen ja und zu verpetzen zu denen
zieren Handy Fotos zu machen und so wir
sind ja so eine einzige verpfeife und
verpetzt Gesellschaft geworden
das tut uns nicht gut nee es tut uns
nicht gut es ist es wird auch alles es
wird alles so wahnsinnig breit getreten
ich meine wir sind auch Teil davon muss
man es auch selbstkritisch mal anmerken
will einen anderen Gedanken noch mal in
in die Runde werfen Richard
die Süddeutsche Zeitung ist zum Teil
auch heftig kritisiert worden wenn man
sagt man kann nicht und das war in
diesem ersten langen Stück das sehr sehr
gut zu lesen war und das das war auch
das problematisch an dem Stück es war
ein richtig gut geschrieben der Text und
man hatte das Gefühl das ist zwingend
das ist logisch ja da hat man jetzt
dieses alte Ding gefunden und dafür die
die rechte Linie ja von von damals zu
dem von dem 17 jährigen einwanger zum
heute 52 53-Jährigen einwanger und das
ist eine ganz klar der hat diesen
braunen Kern über den du gerade
gesprochen hast Roman deiniger der
Kollege von der Süddeutschen nicht
wirklich sehr schätze weil er so einen
ersten ist also lustig Roman ist ein
wahnsinnig lustiger Typ und zweitens der
zum herrlichen Humor der schreibt doch
immer so wunderbare Söder Reportagen
empfehle ich sehr
aber gleichzeitig ist das so ein dessen
Menschenfreund der der marktmensch und
der sagte weißt du mit dem 17-Jährigen
Hubert Aiwanger muss man milder sein mit
dem 52-Jährigen Hubert Aiwanger dagegen
nicht mit dem mit dem muss man im
Zweifel hart ins Gericht gehen
genau
das gleiche was ich auch sage die
Aufarbeitung und den Umgang den eiwanger
damit äh dem Wasser damals gemacht hat
pflegt der ist absolut nicht in Ordnung
ja genau
ja ich wollte nur mal auf einen anderen
Gedanken hinaus was gesagt wird und in
die Richtung argumentiert der Robert
Albaner sagt es ja kein Zufall dass das
jetzt gerade kurz vor der Wahl so
rauskommt diesmal für eine Sekunde um
und findet da muss man die Kollegen
jetzt der Süddeutschen Zeitung mal ganz
klein Schutz nehmen
wenn du so etwas hast
wann soll es denn dann berichten ja nee
das sollte kritischen nach der
Landtagswahl naja doch doch das ist so
das wäre nicht meiner es wäre nicht
meiner wenn meine wenn du dieses
Material jetzt hast und wenn du dich und
wenn du dich dazu entschlossen hast dann
bewegt meine wichtige Entscheidung
richtig das muss an die Öffentlichkeit
dann kannst du das nicht so lange in der
Schublade lassen bis die Wahl gelaufen
ist leider machst du dich quasi indirekt
zum Wahlhelfer das kann ich das kannst
du nicht machen
eine andere Frage ist musst du es
veröffentlichen und B musst du es mit
dem Tenor veröffentlichen das ist der
wahre Eimer das sind die beiden
strittigen Punkt ich weiß du woran ich
denken musste ich habe mal so vor ein
paar Jahren im Interview gehabt James
wahnsinnig beeindruckender Mann der hat
als Staatsanwalt in New York hat er die
großen Mafia Prozesse geführt und so
weiter und es ist so ein ein ganz ganz
aufrechter Kämpfer ich würde sagen für
die Wahrheit
und das war auch derjenige der damals
kurz vor der Wahl kurz vor der war schon
Trump vor 2016 mit diesen E-Mails von
Hillary Clinton noch mal um die Ecke kam
und sagte wir haben da jetzt noch mal
Ermittlungen aufgenommen ganz kurz vor
der Wahl und es wurde ihnen dann
hinterher wurde ihm das wahnsinnig übel
genommen vom von von demokratischer
Seite über die sagten wie könnt ihr
sowas machen das war wirklich 1A
astrein der Wahlkampfhilfe für Donald
Trump das hat den letzten Endes ins Amt
gebracht und er hat mir erzählt von
diesem tiefen gewissen Konflikt den er
hat er gesagt ich habe Nächte lang habe
ich nicht geschlafen weil ich mir
überlegt habe was passiert wenn ich das
jetzt mache ich helfe dem Trump das ist
richtig aber was passiert
genau das ist das eine und das andere
ist er sagte was am Ende ist mir klar
geworden ich bin Staatsanwalt und ich
bin zuständig in diesem Land für die
Wahrheit
und ich bin jetzt hier der fbi-chef und
es geht nur um die Wahrheit und die
Wahrheit muss immer und immer und immer
erzählt werden und wenn die Geschichte
so ist dann ist sie so und notfalls auch
zwei Tage vor der Wahl dann muss die
Geschichte erzählt werden und würde in
dem Fall also
argumentrecht die Süddeutsche ja wenn du
wenn du die Geschichte wenn du die
Geschichte rund hast wenn du die
eidesstattlichen Versicherungen hast
wenn du die Zeugen hast und auch wenn du
sie anonymisiert hast dich bitte dich
darüber hat sich auch viele mokiert und
gesagt haben wir nur anonym erzeugen
präsentiert ich meine ist ein sehr
übliches Vorgehen von investigativen
Journalisten das zu tun und wir reden
hier über Verdachtsberichterstattung und
es ist natürlich relevant die Frage ob
der stellvertretende bayerische
Ministerpräsident irgendwann mal so
etwas verfasst hat und wie er eigentlich
heute so unterwegs ist die Frage kann
man ja stellen und dann muss man auch
stellen das meine ich ja das ist auch
nicht ich
und das und das ist wenn du so willst an
dem Punkt eine ja doch eine
vergleichbare Situation finde ich ja
aber du kannst
zu machen ja aber nein die Kollegen sich
ja auch entscheiden können und könnten
diese Geschichte erzählen können auf der
einen Seite und die Jugend klare
Verfasserschaft und das Flugblatt und
was da drauf stand und so weiter das
kann man alles erzählen und wenn man
meint dass man das in diesem Moment
veröffentlichen muss ich bin immer noch
nicht so ganz sicher aber mal für den
Fall dass das so ist weil das so
Wahrheit förderlich ist wo ist dann der
einordnende Text der diesen Abstand
einzeichnet denn wir haben gerade im
Podcast machen der kann dann Abstand
nach dem Motto das war nicht ist
natürlich alles wahnsinnig lange her und
in den letzten Jahren hat Hubert
einwanger nirgendwo durchblicken lassen
dass er sich diesem Ungeist noch
verpflichtet fühlt das stand da soweit
ich weiß nicht
das kam danach ich glaube da gibt's auch
an nachdenken Roman Deininger meinte zu
mir weißt du wenn Hubert eiwanger
gesagt hätte im Vorfeld hätte sich klar
erklärt und hätte gesagt das war ich gar
nicht das hat mein Bruder geschrieben
dann hätten wir die Geschichte
wahrscheinlich gar nicht gemacht also
insofern ist auch dieser Fall an
weiterer guter Beleg dafür das Politiker
selten über den die eigentliche Affäre
stolpern sondern über den Umgang
das sehe ich ja auch so was hatte ich
als Beispiel von Wolf oder Beckenbauer
oder was weiß ich was erzählen gibt es
noch viele andere Beispiele dafür aber
weißt das liegt immer daran wenn du in
so eine Situation gerät was machst du
dann Berufen an weiter klar
müssen erstmal sehen dass die dir das
glaubhaft und nachweisen müssen nicht du
musst beweisen dass du das Flugzeug
nicht geschrieben hast die müssen dir
beweisen dass du das Flugblatt
geschrieben hast und wie auch immer das
Flugplatz zustande gekommen ist da waren
ein oder zwei Personen in irgendein Dach
kann man mit einer Schreibmaschine und
da gibt's wahrscheinlich keine Zeugen
oder bei der einzige Zeuge sind Bruder
und Bruder
und solange dir niemand irgendwie
nachweisen kannst dazu das gemacht hast
gibt gar nichts zu das ist nicht die
Tipps die man immer vom Anwalt in so
einer Situation bekommt aber
Nachhinein Wulff Beckenbauer und so
weiter werden die wahrscheinlich auch
denken es war falsch ja maximal rein
Tisch machen alles zugeben und dann kann
man sagen hier stehe ich und kann ich
anders ja ich war in Idiot ich habe in
den falschen Kreisen verkehrt ja ich
habe etwas witzig gefunden als mit
17-Jähriger was ich heute nur noch als
Menschen verachten bezeichnen kann und
so weiter und diese Worte sind in dieser
Form nicht gefallen da ist so ein
bisschen rumgedruckst und so ich habe
mir diese Antworten auf den Fragebogen
ja ich habe Flugplatz ja nicht
geschrieben und nee deswegen kann ich
mich auch nicht mehr erinnern ich weiß
ja auch gar nichts mehr und so und da
tut mir leid nehme
ja also an so eine Situation dass du in
der Schule von Untersuchungsausschuss
kommst dass du von der Schule fliegen
kannst und so weiter und du sagst du
kannst ja nichts erinnern das Quatsch
aber jetzt komme jetzt noch mal zum
Schluss an ein interessanten Punkt wenn
du sagst du glaubst ihm das nicht er
sagt das aber er sagt das so das kann ja
auch von der sagt er sagt zum Beispiel
auch da muss man die Frage stellen kann
jemand der so ein schlechtes Gedächtnis
hat stellvertretender
mindestens nicht ernst gemeint aber
es kann ja durchaus sein dass alles was
er gesagt hat Rechte und dass er sich
nicht erinnern kann also im Zweifelsfall
muss das immer als mögliche Option im
Raum bleibt und was was mich zum
Beispiel in der gesamten Geschichte in
der Gesamtbetrachtung ja wenn man das
jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen Revue
passieren lässt was mich wirklich massiv
stört ist mittlerweile dieser Sound der
der da so entstanden ist
es ist eigentlich fast egal ob er es
geschrieben hat oder nicht und ich finde
auf den Punkt muss man immer wieder
hinarbeiten das ist eben gerade nicht
egal es ist unter einem Gesichtspunkt
egal 35 Jahre her ist ist es egal
unter dem Aspekt ist es egal aber unter
dem Aspekt heute reinen Tisch zu machen
so ist es nicht egal das sind zwei
verschiedene Dinge das meine ich auch
und wenn er sagt ich was nicht und
niemand von medialer Seite kann ihm das
Gegenteil beweisen dann sollten wir dann
irgendwann noch mal sagen so dann ist
aber auch mal gut und dann muss es auch
dieses Momentum geben und man sagt jetzt
ist jetzt ist auch mal Feierabend ich
finde ja politisch hat der Söder Markus
Söder hat das brillant abgeholt ja sonst
machen also wenn er wenn er er schafft
ein Märtyrer wenn er ihn kurz vor der
Landtagswahl feiert und er kann danach
nicht mehr leise Pfeifen mit dem Freien
Wählern eine Koalition eingehen wichtig
also deswegen du musst gar nicht
verlieren sein es gibt nur eine
Handlungsoption ja ich er hat sich auf
Charlotte Knobloch Berufen ne das fand
ich interessant die die 90 Jahre alt
mittlerweile
Frau mit einer sehr bewegenden
Geschichte ihre ganze Familie ist
Holocaust umgekommen von Nazis ermordet
worden sie selber hat überlebt weil sie
glaube ich von einer von einer
Hausangestellten ist sie ist sie
versteckt worden von einer haushälteren
irgendwo von dem Bauernhof und hat das
das ganze so überstanden ist eine echte
moralische Instanz und übrigens der
Grund das wusste ich nicht vielleicht
wusstest du das Richard der Grund warum
es in München auf den Straßen Münchens
gibt es keine Stolpersteine die zum
aufgefallen mir nicht nee es gibt keine
Stolpersteine in München und offenkundig
aus Respekt vor genau dieser Frau vor
Charlotte Knobloch weil die sagt
Stolpersteine mit Boden alles was
sozusagen auf dem Boden ist tue ich mich
wahnsinnig schwierig werden ja ich habe
die nee ich habe diese Bilder im Kopf
wie damals Juden auf dem Boden lagen und
getreten worden sind und misshandelt
worden sind und teilweise totgeschlagen
worden sind und damit hat die so ein
Problem und deswegen hat sie ein Problem
mit Stolperstein auf dem Boden ja wusste
ich nicht ich ich will nur darauf hinaus
Markus Söder sagt ich habe mich mit ihr
ausgetauscht und sie wiederum hat sich
mit Hubert Eingang ausgetauscht hat auch
seine Entschuldigung nicht angenommen
hat ihm sehr klar gesagt was sie davon
hält und hat dann aber in der Abwägung
Söder den Rat gegeben entlassen bitte
nicht und zwar mit der Begründung mach
keinen Märtyrer aus ihm genau wenn du
ihn wenn du ihn entlässt ist der Schaden
am Ende weit größer als wenn du nicht
entlässt
man muss sich ja das politische Terra in
Bayern auch mal anschauen wir kennen
alle noch die Zeiten als Franz-Josef
Strauß seine absolute Mehrheit geholt
hat heute splittet sich das
wlan-potential von damals auf drei
Parteien auf und die anderen beiden sind
ja nicht klein also die Freien Wähler
und die AFD
und das ist ja alles zusammen ein
ziemlich gewaltiges Potenzial und der
Traum eines jeden CSU-Vorsitzenden muss
ja eigentlich immer darin sitzen die
wieder heim in die Familie zu holen was
unter Strauß ja noch möglich war also
das alles zu klammern ne der berühmte
Satz von Franz-Josef Strauß rechts von
mir ist nur noch die Wand oder die
rechts von CSU ist nur noch die Wand da
darf nichts sein da darf kein kein Raum
mehr entstehen lassen genau das ist
natürlich im 21 Jahrhundert mit seiner
veränderten politischen Topographie
nicht mehr realistisch na wenn man
versuchen würde heute die AFD
tatsächlich noch so zu integrieren dass
man ihre Position im csu-parteiprogramm
unterbringt dann dann zerreißt es die
Partei also man hat ja nicht freiwillig
gehen lassen sondern das ist eine
Sollbruchstelle gewesen die musste
irgendwann aufreißen aber wenn man sieht
an diesem Beispiel das weit mehr als die
Hälfte aller in Bayern wählen den
Menschen
eine Position einnehmen die von Mitte
bis rechts geht und dann dein solchen
Keil reinzumachen dass man sich also mit
dem Vorsitzenden der Freien Wähler dass
man den öffentlich fallen lässt dann
kriegt die CSU und Identitätsprobleme in
Bayern und ich glaube das ist wieder
vollkommen klar gewesen von Anfang an
insofern spannender Fall spannende
Geschichte und irgendwie noch viel
gelernt auch in der Reflexion über
unsere eigene Arbeit ne letzten Endes
über die Rolle auch von Medien die Art
und Weise wie wir es Gesellschaft ticken
und so weiter ist dieser Fall alberner
ein sehr interessanter Fall ja ich hatte
so vieles zusammen kommt also es ist das
was worüber wir unlängst ja geredet
haben öffentliche dienststation und
Vorverurteilung spielt hier mit rein
aber es spielt eben auch die die Frage
rein umgehen mit ähm
Dingen die man in seiner Jugend gemacht
hat ja so ist sie zu denen man aus guten
Gründen nicht mehr stehen kann und in
diesem Fall auch noch ziemlich
widerliche Sachen
das ist ein zweites großes Thema und das
dritte große Thema ist in welche
Richtung wird Deutschland unter solchen
vorzeichendriften das bestürzende daran
ist dass der Rechtspopulismus durch
diese Geschichte eigentlich nur gewinnt
also wenn sich Herr Aiwanger in
Bierzelten jetzt als aufrechter Kämpfer
und so weiter für seine Sache und die
Sache des deutschen Volkes und so weiter
feiern lässt dann geht diese ganze
Geschichte am Ende ja ganz bitte aus ja
also die einzigen die einzige Gewinner
an der ganzen Geschichte wird dann der
Populismus sein und die Leute die sagen
in diesem Land darf man ja nicht mehr
sein wie man ist oder nicht mehr sagen
was man denkt und das ist die große
Gefahr die am Ende darin steht und auch
das ist einer der Gründe warum die doch
recht offensichtliche heulenlosigkeit
von Aiwanger
eine ziemlich gefährliche Geschichte ist
und das vierte Thema richard ist
sozusagen die Frage es gibt in der
Juristerei diesen Begriff oder diese
Idee ist es rechts auf vergessen ja und
ich finde das muss es geben das Recht
auf vergessen ist ein also es gibt diese
diesen Recht das Recht darauf dass nicht
alles mit der Neonlicht beleuchtet wird
ist ein
ur-urrecht des Liberalismus der
Liberalismus hat immer gesagt es gibt
Dinge die geht die Öffentlichkeit nichts
an es muss ein Recht darauf geben auf
private Verhaltensweisen damit meine ich
jetzt nicht das eiwagner Flugblatt dass
man nicht so ganz grundsätzlich und ganz
generell ja und wenn das grelle
Scheinwerfer liegt der Öffentlichkeit in
alles eindringt was Menschen die in der
Öffentlichkeit stehen tun
dann werden irgendwann nur noch Zombies
in der Öffentlichkeit stehen können und
keine Menschen aus Fleisch und Blut mehr
genau das ist der Punkt schönes
Schlusswort
dank dir sehr für diesen Austausch wir
hören uns nächste Woche ja
danke
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]